.
>> Greg: HAPPY GLORIOUS MONDAY
EVERYONE WHAT A GREAT MONDAY FOR
YOU, ME AND AMERICA BECAUSE OUR
AUDIENCE IS BACK.
YOU HEARD THEM.
TAKE THAT WUHAN LAB.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME.
AND WE'RE IN A BRAND NEW STUDIO.
YEAH.
SO THEY TELL ME.
ALTHOUGH I DID FIND ONE OF CHRIS
WALLACE'S OLD TO YOU PAYS IN MY
DRESSING ROOM.
IT SMELLED.
BUT NO MORE TAPING FROM THE
MEN'S ROOM AT DENNY'S.
THOUGH I'LL LEAVE THOSE CAMERAS
UP JUST IN CASE.
CHECK THIS PLACE OUT, LET'S DO A
SWEEP AROUND HERE.
HOW BEAUTIFUL IS THIS, HUH?
YEAH.
THEY DID A GREAT JOB, AN AMAZING
JOB.
I HAVEN'T, I HAVEN'T BEEN THIS
EXCITED SINCE GERALDO REMOVED
ALL HIS CLOTHES TO GET A BOOSTER
SHOT ON HIS LEFT ARM.
YEAH, HE COULDN'T JUST ROLL UP
HIS SLEEVE.
HE'S THE ONLY PERSON I KNOW WHO
TAKES HIS SHIRT OFF WHILE
GETTING A PEDICURE.
YOU SHOULD SEE WHAT HE DID FOR
HIS COLONOSCOPY OR AS HE CALLED
IT EXPLORING AL CAPONE'S VAULT.
NEVER LET HIM FORGET IT BUT
TONIGHT WE'VE GOT GREAT GUESTS
RIGHT?
MIKE ROWE'S HERE TONIGHT.
TALK ABOUT A GUY WHO LOVES TO
ROLL UP HIS SLEEVES.
BUT HE LOOKS GREAT ROLLING UP
ANYTHING, INCLUDING A DEAD BODY
IN AN AREA RUG.
WHO HASN'T BEEN THERE?
AND THERE'S THE GREAT
JOHN TAFFER.
HIS CLOTHES HAVE BEEN IN MORE
DINGY BARS THAN KAT TIMPF ON
SAINT PATRICK'S DAY.
A GROUP WHO SAY IT'S RACIST WHO
RETURN TO A PHYSICAL OFFICE.
WOULDN'T IT JUST BE EASIER AT
THIS POINT IF BABIES LISTED THE
THINGS THEY DON'T THINK ARE
RACIST.
BUT THEY CLAIM THAT IN-PERSON
WORK WOULD MAKE APPLE'S WORK
FORCE WHITER, MORE MALE
DOMINATED AND LESS DIVERSE.
THEY'RE CALLED APPLE TOGETHER,
WHICH IS ODD GIVEN THEY REFER TO
REMAIN APART.
THE EMPLOYEES WROTE AN OPEN
LETTER CONDEMNING RETURNING TO
WORK AFTER THE CEO ANNOUNCED
THEY WOULD NEED TO WORK IN THE
OFFICE ONE DAY A WEEK.
YEAH, ONE DAY A WEEK.
WHAT WE CALL BIDEN HOURS.
AND COOK SAID THEY WOULD RAMP UP
FROM 1-3 DAYS A WEEK, YEAH,
THREE, BY MID MAY.
THREE DAYS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
IF THIS HEATS UP, BY 2024,
THEY'LL HAVE TO SHOW UP FIVE
DAYS A WEEK.
THIS GROUP IS ALL ABOUT THE
OPPRESSED, APPARENTLY.
EXCEPT FOR THE 12 YEAR OLD
CHINESE GIRLS CHAINED TO HER
WORKBENCH FOR 15 HOURS WITHOUT A
ME BREAK ASSEMBLING iPHONES.
YOU WON'T HEAR APPLE SAYING
THEY'LL GIVE UP THEIR CUSHIE
JOBS AND TURN THEM OVER TO THE
UNDERPRIVILEGED BUT IT'S JUST
ABOUT FEELINGS.
WE'RE A CULTURE THAT DECIDED
FEELINGS CANNOT BE QUESTIONED SO
WE LET FALSE CONCERNS TO MUSCLE
OUT REAL CONCERNS.
NOW THEY'RE NO LONGER JUST
EMPLOYEES, THEY'RE VICTIMS.
JUST THINK HOW DEHYDRATED THEY
COULD GET FROM ALL THAT AIR
CONDITIONING.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
WELL, MY GUESTS DID NOT GET TO
WHERE THEY WERE IN LIFE BASED ON
PROTECTING ONE'S FEELINGS.
AND UNLIKE ME, NOT BECAUSE OF
THEIR GOOD LOOKS.
NO, THEY MAKE THINGS WORK BASED
ON HARSH SOBRIETY, EVERY JOB
DOESN'T CONSIDER ONES FEELINGS
UNLESS THOSE FEELINGS ARE YOUR
THUMB BEING SLICED BY A ROTARY
BLADE.
AND EVEN THEN I SAY PUT THE
THUMB IN YOUR POCKET FINISH THE
JOCK AND GO TO THE ER.
BUT IN A SOCIETY CRUMBLING YOU
SHOULDN'T BE WORRIED ABOUT
FEELINGS P I DON'T WANT TO DRIVE
ACROSS A BING WHO WIFE CHEATED
SO HE USED BALLS A WOOD.
BRIDGES HAVE TO STAY UP AND FOR
THAT YOU DON'T NEED EMOTION YOU
NEED ENGINEERING.
ENGINEER MAKE THE WORLD GO
AROUND, THEY LET APPLE EMPLOYEES
WINE ALL DAY BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY DID THE HEAVY LIFTING.
WOULDN'T IT BE NICE IF THEY DID
JOBS THAT DIDN'T EFFECT THE REST
OF US LIKE BEING A PRODUCER AT
THE JOE SHOW.
BUT THEY DON'T THEY WORK AT
APPLE THAT MAKES THINGS OR
DISNEY THAT GROOMS I MEAN
ENTERTAINS KIDS.
THEY BRING THEIR IDIOCY WITH
THEM.
NOT A BIG DEAL IF IT'S NETFLIX
BUT IF THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO NAKE
A STURDY BRIDGE THAT'S SCARY.
WE'RE AT THE POINT WHERE SOMEONE
COULD ARGUE WHEN TWO PLUS TWO
DON'T REALLY ADD UP TO FOUR IT
COULD IDENTIFY AS FIVE.
WHY CAN'T A NUMBER BE NON-BINARY
JUST LIKE MY MATH TEACHER WHO
ONLY SHAVED HALF HER HEAD.
IMAGINE IF OTHER OCCUPATIONS
WORKED FROM HOME.
[PHONE RINGING.
>> JOE'S PLUMBING YOU LOG THEM
WE UNCLOG THEM.
>> YOU HAVE TO HELP ME, OKAY, MY
TOILET IS SPRAYING WATER
EVERYWHERE.
>> OKAY, NO PROBLEM, WE CAN DO
THIS ON ZOOM.
JUST HOLD YOUR LAPTOP OVER THE
BOWL AND WHAT'S YOUR TOILET'S
PASSWORD.
>> PASSWORD?
IT'S A TOILET.
>> LOOKS LIKE WHAT YOU GOT THERE
IS A TOILET SPRAYING WATER.
TELL YOU WHAT.
UNPLUG IT, WAIT ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES AND THEN PLUG IT BACK
IN.
THAT WILL BE 500 BUCKS FOR THE
CONSULTATION.
I'VE GOT TO GO, MIKE ROWE'S ON
LINE TWO.
.
>> Greg: TODAY LET'S CELEBRATE
WORK AND THE PEOPLE WHO DO IT.
THEY CLOSE THEIR MOUTHS, ROLL UP
THEIR SLEUTHS AND THEY GET THE
JOB DONE.
THEY DO THE MATH SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE'S MY FAVOR ROWE AFTER CORN,
SPARE AND ISOMETRICS, HOST OF
HOW AMERICA WORKS ON FOX
BUSINESS, MIKE ROWE!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HE KNOWS RESCUING BARS
LIKE I KNOW GETTING THROWN OUT
OF THEM.
HOST OF BAR RESCUE ON PARAMOUNT
NETWORK AND THE BOOK THE POWER
OF CONFLICT JON TAFFER.
SHE'S LIKE HER CHECKING ACCOUNT
ALWAYS UNBALANCED.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
SAN AT HIS HEIGHT ALL FRUIT IS
LOW HANGING FRUIT.
WORLD CHAMPION TYRUS.
>> WELCOME TO THE FIRST NIGHT OF
THIS, JOHN
>> Kat: GREG, JUST QUICKLY, WE
HAVE TAFFER AND MIKE ROWE ON,
THIS IS THE GUYEST GUY TOWN OF
ALL GUY TOWNS.
>> Tyrus: I LIKE GUY TOWN.
>> Greg: THIS IS A GUY TOWN
TONIGHT.
I THINK WE HAVE SOMETHING TO
CELEBRATE IT.
♪♪
GUY TOWN, PROVIDED FOR YOUR
FAMILY AND PAYING BILLS, THEN
YOU GRILL A STEAK, CHOPPING WOOD
WITH YOUR SHIRT OFF AND
VOLUNTEERING, BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GIVE BACK TO YOUR
COMMUNITY WITH JOHN, MIKE, TYRUS
AND GREG.
ULTIMATE GUY TOWN.
WOO!
>> Reporter: GUY TOWN.
SO JOHN WELCOME TO GUY TOWN.
THE POWER OF CONFLICT.
OKAY, THIS BOOK GOES AGAINST
EVERYTHING I JUST DID IN THE
MONDAY LOG.
LIKE NO ONE WANTS TO TALK BACK,
NO ONE WANTS TO ENGAGE PEOPLE
FOR FEAR OF CALLING NAMES.
HOW WOULD YOU ADVISE TIM COOK.
>> I THINK TIM COOK SHOULD SPEAK
THAT.
I MEAN WE HAVE TO SAY WHAT WE
BELIEVE.
IF WE ALL STOP SAYING WHAT WE
BELIEVE, WHAT WE BELIEVE
DISAPPEARS.
SO HOW DO WE PROTECT WHAT WE
BELIEVE IF WE DON'T SPEAK UP.
SO THE PURPOSES OF THE BOOK WAS
TO GIVE PEOPLE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO
STICK UP FOR THE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR.
>> Greg: ANY GOOD BARS YOU'VE
BEEN TO LATELY.
>>.
>> Jon: UNFORTUNATELY THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS I'VE BEEN IN
PRODUCTION.
GETS WORSE AND WORSE.
THE PAIN IS REAL.
>> Reporter: YEAH THE PAIN IS
RULE.
CLEARLY COVID HAS CHANGED THE
WAY WE WORK BUT ONE DAY IN THE
OFFICE THAT IS KIND OF A
HARDSHIP, DON'T YOU AGREE?
>> Mike: IT'S GOING TO BE FUN TO
WATCH HOW THIS PLAYS OUT
HONESTLY WITH RESPECT TO TIM AND
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE IN HIS
POSITIONS, THEY'RE THE CLOUDS
FROM WHICH THE SNOWFLAKES FELL,
RIGHT?
>> YES I.
>> Mike: SO WE'RE DEALING IN A
WEIRD WAY, I READ EVERYTHING
THAT APPLE SENT AND IT'S A LIST
OF DEMANDS.
RIGHT?
THEY DIDN'T PICK UP THE PHONE
AND SAY MR. COOK WE WOULD LOVE
TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU AND TALK
ABOUT IDEAS REGARDING WORK/LIFE
BALANCE AND SO FORTH.
THEY LISTED DEMANDS.
AND SO WHAT'S HE GOING TO DO,
YOU KNOW?
WHEN A KID THROWS A TEMPER
TANTRUM, WHAT DOES THE PARENT
DO.
DO YOU NEGOTIATE WITH A
TERRORIST?
WHAT DO YOU DO?
SO HE'S IN A SITUATION RIGHT NOW
AND IT'S -- I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
HIS MOVE IS GOING TO BE BUT I'M
PRETTY SURE THAT IF THE
EMPLOYEES ARE ALLOWED TO
DETERMINE WHEN THEY WORK, HOW
MUCH THEY WORK AND WHAT THEY DO,
GUYS LIKE TIM ARE GOING TO THINK
TWICE BEFORE STARTING A
BUSINESS.
>> Reporter:.
>> Greg: YEAH I WOULD NOT WANT
TO START A BUSINESS RIGHT NOW
UNLESS IT'SING? REALLY COOL LIKE
MAKING DUNE BUGGIES.
>> Mike: BUILDINGS ARE NOT
CREDULOUR PEOPLE ARE.
SNOWBELT YEAH.
THE THING THAT KILLS ME ABOUT
THIS TYRUS IS THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF PRIVILEGE IN
THAT THEY HAVE A JOB THAT ALLOWS
THEM NOT TO HAVE TO TRAVEL.
LIKE A PLUMBER DOES NOT HAVE
WORK AT HOME PRIVILEGES.
>> Tyrus: NEITHER DO I.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY YOU COMMUTE
PRETTY FAR.
>> Tyrus: YEAH, IN A PLANE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Tyrus: YOU NEVER TOLD ME I
COULD COME IN ONE DAY.
>> Greg: ALTHOUGH DULL FOR A
WHILE.
>> Tyrus: YEAH, I DID.
BOY, THAT WAS A HELL OF A RUN R
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE THINGS.
THE WORD RACIST KEEPS COMING UP,
RIGHT?
RACIST, RACIST.
THEY MADE A STATEMENT THAT IF WE
BROUGHT PEOPLE INTO WORK, THAT
IT WOULD BECOME RACIST BECAUSE
ALL THE WHITE GUYS WOULD SHOW
UP.
I'M GOING TO SAY THAT AGAIN.
>> THAT'S SO GOOD.
>> Tyrus: IF WE ALL HAVE TO GO
TO WORK, THE ONLY ONES THAT SHOW
UP TO WORK ARE WHITE GUYS.
SO I HAD -- DO WE HAVE THE
DEFINITION -- THEY CLEARLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT A RACIST IS.
DO WE HAVE THE DICTIONARY, THE
DEFINITION FOR RACIST.
DOES EVERYONE SEE IT.
I DON'T HAVE MY GLASSES BUT I'M
ASSUMING TO THE EFFECT WHEN YOU
DON'T LIKE PEOPLE THAT LOOK OR
THINK LIKE YOU, RIGHT?
LE TV WOKE'S VERSION OF RACISM.
>> OR THE JOKE VERSION OF RACISM
>> Kat: YEAH, I READ THAT
STATEMENT SO MANY TIMES BECAUSE
THEY SAID IT WAS RACIST AND I
KEPT WAITING TO SEE WHY.
AND I WAS LIKE, CAN I NOT READ?
BUT THEY JUST DIDN'T PUT A
REASON WHY.
WHICH I THINK THEY USED TO AT
LEAST MAKE SOMETHING UP SAY IT'S
RACIST BECAUSE OF THIS OR THAT
HISTORY OF THIS WORD USED THIS
WAY.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN TRY THEY SAID
IT'S JUST RACIST.
>> Greg: IT ALSO BENEFITS THE
NEURO NORMTIVE.
WHAT IS THAT.
>> Mike: YEAH, NEUROTYPICAL AS
SOMEONE NOT NEUROTYPICAL I MAKE
IT TO WORK EVERY DAY.
>> Greg: TRUE.
IT'S AMAZING YOU GET TO WORK.
>> Mike: YEAH.
HARDER ON SOME MORNINGS THAN
OTHERS.
>> Jon: MIKE RACES A GOOD POINT
AND EVEN BE IN MY BOOK, CONFLICT
IS SITTING DOWN AND ENGAGING
WITH PEOPLE TALKING WITH THEM
NOT GIVING THEM ULTIMATUMS.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY TO START THE
DISCUSSION.
>> Tyrus: YEAH BUT THE BARNS DID
THE DISCUSSING WITH THEM THE
BULLDOZING AND THEN THEY GET IN
THE REAL WORLD AND SOMEONE ASKS
THEM A QUESTION AND THEY'RE
LIKE, MOM?
THAT'S WHY NO ONE SAYS ANYTHING.
>> Greg: DURING A JOB INTERVIEW
ONCE A GUY WHERE I WORK BROUGHT
HIS PARENTS.
>> Tyrus: YES, HE DID.
>> Greg: THAT WAS IN THE 90s.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
THAT.
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE SHE
SAID THAT WAS REALLY SMART?
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
BRIDGE BUILDING AND ENGINEERING.
AND I GET THESE EVERY SO OFTEN
SOMEBODY OFFERS ME AN HONORARY
DEGREE, RIGHT?
YOU GO TO A COLLEGE AND YOU SAY
SOME WORDS.
>> Tyrus: HAPPENS TO ME ALL THE
TIME.
>> IT'S GOING TO.
EVERYONE'S GETTING THEM AND YOU
DON'T SEE HONORARY DEGREES IN
ELECTRIC.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Mike: YOU DON'T SEE THEM IN
TRADE SCHOOL
>> Kat: THAT'S WHAT I WANT,
HONORARY PLUMBER.
>> Mike: I WANT TO BE AN
HONORARY DOCTOR, GIVE IT A SHOT.
>> Greg: I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE
DR. JILL OPERATE ON ME.
OF COURSE SHE IS A DOCTOR.
SHE IS A DOCTOR.
BUT SHE'S NOT REMOVING MY
GALLBLADDER.
UNLESS SHE WANTS TO.
>> Mike: SHE'S NOT GOIN
.
>> Tyrus: SHE'S NOT GOING TO
SHOW UP TO WORK ANYWAY BECAUSE
ONLY WHITE GUYS SHOW UP TO WORK.
I WOULD PUNC